all right dissonance pans we've got the
scoop on your favorite cast members from
the aisle and our Adhan prep these
outrageous facts are just too juicy to
keep to ourselves stay tuned to the end
to see which cast member has to wear zit
cream at night and how the cast is
really giving along on the set of d3 if
you're new here stay up to date with our
latest videos by clicking that
notification bell and click the thumbs
up button if you love the cast and
descendants 3 as much as we do now here
are the outrageous facts we uncovered
about the secret lives of the
descendants cast dove Cameron and Thomas
Doherty breakup rumors first they are
just cast mates then friends then they
became everyone's relationship goals but
there are some recent rumors that the
two called it quits
some fans saw an Instagram video that
dub posted where she appears to be
throwing some serious shade Thomas's way
her expression definitely changed when
he showed up behind her but was it a
lover's quarrel or something more
serious dub put the rumors to rest on
her instapage when she posted a cute
video of them she wrote that they're
still dating nothing's wrong they are
not fighting they are happy and in love
and it's smooth sailing all right dub we
believe you descendants was Sofia's
first movie ever so everyone knows that
Cameron voice and of Chairman were
already Disney stars and booboo Stewart
made his on-screen debut in the Twilight
movies but Sophia Carson had never been
in a movie before can you guys believe
that you can tell it all by her awesome
performance here's a little secret we
uncovered when Sophia originally
auditioned for descendants she
auditioned for the role of Audrey you
know the princess daughter of Aurora and
Sleeping Beauty's Princess Aurora and
Prince Philip but during the 5-month
casting process the producers agreed
that Sophia was a better fit as Eevee
real talk we couldn't be happier about
that china anne mcclain and lauren
McClain are twins Chyna and McClain who
plays the role of uma in dissonance 2 &
3 looks almost identical to her sister
and
hello actress / singer Lauren McLain
many people have told them they look
like twins even though they are almost
two years apart
the sisters are pretty close they even
got matching tattoos on the sides of
their torsos one tattoo says sy amis if
you please the other tattoo says sy amis
if you don't please
can anyone guess where the song lyric is
from if you guessed Disney's lady in the
[ __ ] you're a winner
the lines are sung in the film by two
mischievious Siamese cats booboo Stewart
ran a marathon booboo Stewart can sing
dance act and sword fight but did you
know that he was also a long-distance
runner like really long distance the LA
marathon is 26.2 agonizing miles across
the city and booboo Stewart tore it up
like the villain bad boy he is or plays
in the movies athleticism must be pretty
important to this multi-talented guy he
is also quite limber
Cameron boys posted a video of him and
booboo doing the splits when they heard
the news about descendants three-beam
greenlit these are some flexible dudes
maybe we'll get to see more of that in
the next movie Cameron Boyce is social
media got hacked
speaking of Cameron Boyce on social
media we found out that his social media
accounts got hacked not once but twice
yikes it sounds like Cameron needs to
pick a harder password anyway he took to
Instagram to talk about what had
happened and his love / hate
relationship with social media he said
he has always thought that social media
should take a backseat to real life even
if it is a big part of his career he
said that even though getting hacked
twice in one week wasn't fun he honestly
doesn't really care about Instagram oh
the irony of posting on social media to
talk about how you don't care about
social media we still love you Cameron
Sophia Carson hosted last year's Radio
Disney Music Awards and it was awesome
last year at the Rd amazed
Sophia Carson made her musical
performance debut and she said it was
surreal she shared that she had never
really performed like that before being
onstage singing and dancing at the same
time
since it was also her first TV show she
spent a lot of time prepping and
rehearsing she was performing on the
same stage as Ariana Grande and Gwen
Stefani that night so she had to be at
her best
this year Sofia is nominated for an RD
MA for her song in and outs in the
category of best crush song Congrats
Sophia we hope you win
the cast just celebrated Karen Boyce's
19th birthday together you guys remember
that earlier video that dove Cameron
posted where people said she was giving
some serious side ID to her boyfriend
Thomas well in that video dub was
wishing her beloved cast mate Cameron
Boyce a happy birthday
dove wrote that she thinks cam is magic
she said thanks to him for letting her
cry on him for the last five years and
that she loves him
Sophia also posted a sweet picture of
her and Cameron with the caption wishing
a happy birthday to her not so little
brother and that she loves him forever
well Cameron if you have to work on your
birthday this seems like the ideal job
to do it on dub Cameron gets it's like
the rest of us okay okay one more thing
about that video dove Cameron posted
where she's wishing Cameron Boyce a
happy birthday
in addition to the sweet birthday wishes
she wrote that cam turned 19 and it made
the fire alarms go off in the middle of
the night it looks like they're at their
hotel
Cameron joke said everyone came out of
their rooms just to wish him a happy
birthday then it appears that dove has
these little white dots on her face dove
must have remembered what she had on her
face because she says who else has got
zit cream on lol Dylan Playfair loves to
travel
Dylan Playfair is the handsome slightly
goofy pirate on umas crew his
character's name is Gill and he is the
son of Beauty and the beasts Gaston well
when he is not sword fighting and
dancing on a pirate ship
Dylan Playfair loves to travel he loves
the great outdoors The Descendants to
star has been to Thailand Cambodia
Vietnam Korea France England to the
Netherlands most of the US and all of
Canada he posted a gorgeous picture of
Thailand on his Instagram page with a
caption that said he was home for the
next couple
days that's not a bad place to call home
Sophia Carson is starring in Pretty
Little Liars the perfectionists you
remember how he told you that dissonance
with Sophia's first film role well she
must have really loved it because she
has since hosted the Radio Disney Music
Awards and now she is starring in
preforms Pretty Little Liars the
perfectionists according to the preview
she posted on her Instagram page this
show is going to be awesome Sophia will
be playing the role of Ava a
trend-setting block setter and coder who
strives to be a fashion icon Sophia is
also playing a reoccurring role on
another freeform show famous in love hmm
it seems like this songbird got bit by
the acting bug dove Cameron has dated
girls after dove Cameron posted a
snapchat video of her kissing the
upcoming star of the new flash movie
Kiersey Clemons the fan verse assumed
she likes dating girls as well as boys
she also toyed with fans on Twitter
about the subject saying that she had a
love for people in her own gender then
she joked to the boys to watch out or
she is going to steal their girl there
were also rumors that dove Cameron dated
fellow Disney star Bella Thorne who is
openly by the Stars responded to a
question from fans about whether they
had considered hooking up with a lot of
flirty emojis dove posted hashtag power
couple in response
Cameron voices BFFs are squad goals so
by now you know how Cameron boys spent
his 19th birthday he was working on the
set of the upcoming dissonance theory
movie while he was surrounded by his
adoring cast mates like Tov Cameron and
Sophia Carson he couldn't be with all of
his friends and family he was all the
way in Vancouver Canada where they were
filming so what did his best friend's
Punk star Karan Brar and actor Sophia
Reynolds do they hopped on a plane to
Vancouver to wish their best friend a
happy birthday in person
talk about squad goals Cameron seemed
pretty happy about their arrival don't
you think
Sophia Carson played Coachella said it
was a dream come true
Sophia Carson is totally living the
dream that is if your dream is to star
in
hit Disney movies to hit TV shows to
host the Radio Disney Music Awards and
to perform for a huge crowd on stage at
one of the biggest music festivals ever
so be opposed to the picture on
Instagram of her rocking out in her
fringe dress in front of a crowd of
screaming fans
she wrote that the moment she played
Coachella was like something out of a
dream the look on her face in that
picture says it all this talented lady
was born to Sparkle dental hygiene is
important to China and McLean China and
McClain has several priorities in her
life she was dedicated to her family and
her sisters she loves to sing and dance
she loves playing the role of uma in
dissonance 2 & 3 and dental hygiene is
super important to her how do we know
because she appeared next to this giant
tooth at the Children's Health Fund and
Guardian launch event in New York City
during the evening China helped to teach
kindergarten and first-grade students
all about the importance of good hygiene
that girl is flossing and she is good at
taking care of her teeth how cute is
that huge tooth Karen voice is a total
mama's boy
Cameron Boyce loves his mother one might
even say he's a total mama's boy but in
a sweet way not in the creepy Norman
Bates kind of way Cameron recently
posted a picture of him and his mother
petting a cheetah on his Instagram
profile he said he would outrun this
cheetah if it meant he got to keep her
as a mom oh that's so sweet
he wished her a happy birthday and wrote
that she was the greatest gift in his
life he said he missed her and couldn't
wait to see her
his mom must be very proud of him he
seems to have a very good heart Cheyenne
Jackson as Hades true fans have already
heard that Hades is making an appearance
in descendants three possibly as Mel's
dad the news is that Cheyenne Jackson
was cast in the role as the blue flame
haired villain in the upcoming movie the
Broadway star is known for his work on
American Horror Story and he seems
perfect to play the role of Hades but
getting worked wasn't always easy for
him he shared in an interview that being
open
gay has sometimes been a detriment to
his acting career he believes he may
have lost a couple of roles because of
it but doesn't mine because being out is
very freeing what Kenny Ortega says
about booboo Stewart in real life booboo
Stewart who plays Jay the son of Jafar
and the descendents movies is so fun to
watch on screen you can just tell he's a
genuine guy with a lot of heart so it
was no surprise to us when Kimmy Ortega
said that booboo was humble kind and
courteous add that to the fact that he
can fence sing dance act and has hair
for days and you've got the whole
package still it's nice to get that type
of compliments from a huge director like
Kenny Ortega we wonder if he's blushing
dylan Playfair has three brothers here's
another fun fact about dylan play fair
dylan is one of three brothers he really
loves spending time with them he even
posted the picture of his family saying
that he loves these fellas and called
them the boys Oh summer it seems that
his family has done a good job of
keeping him grounded a few other fun
facts about Dylan he loves country music
he played junior hockey in Canada before
becoming an actor and says he still
plays with friends when he can he also
loves water sports like wait for teen
and deep-sea diving
he's an adventurous guy for sure Sophia
Carson needs two and a half hours to get
into character it takes a while to get
that blue wig looking good and on
straight and then there's that mater
costume in all the accessories for
Sophia to become evey it takes about two
and a half hours total from start to
finish and that doesn't include learning
her lines dance rehearsals sword
training and everything else she has to
do to prep for her role since Sophia is
a fashionista who loves hair and makeup
she really enjoyed watching herself
transform into the role it gave her time
to learn her lines and relax a bit
before the physical scenes she has to do
they are all like family the cast of
descendants have become one big happy
family
they have celebrated birthdays together
they have laughed cried and sang
together and they have even played a few
pranks on each other they posted
pictures together when they started
working on descendants three calling
each other
you can see that they all have really
bonded and formed lifelong relationships
through the process of making these
unforgettable films we hope they stay
best friends forever so who is your
favorite descendants cast member let us
know in the comments and that about
wraps it up on the descendents cast
thanks for popping by see you next time
on the things
[Music]